que ce soit pour des vacances en famille
un week-end en amoureux ou du tourisme
d'affaires l'association dormir en
vallée de chevreuse propose aujourd'hui
18 hébergement dans le parc régional
créé il ya plus de 15 ans par trois
hébergeurs de la ville de magny les
hameaux
cette association ne cherche pas
simplement à proposer un toit mais
également une certaine qualité d'accueil
sont des hébergements qui sont
sélectionnés pour leurs qualités
d'hébergement et aussi la qualité de
leur accueil
puisque dormir en vallée de chevreuse à
une charte à respecter
il ya par exemple l'accueil des hôtes
être présent respecter l'environnement
puisque on est quand même sur le parc
naturel l'éventail est très large il y
avait des gîtes des chambres d'hôtes des
meublés de tourisme
sachant que la chambre d'hôte comporte
automatiquement un petit déjeuner servi
ce n'est pas le cas forcément dû meubler
au du gîte
l'un des objectifs de l'association est
de mettre en avant des hébergements
aussi agréable cas typique comme c'est
ici le cas dans la grance de la gueule à
aimerais réaménagé en gîte par ses
propriétaires il ya une dizaine d'années
ketty mans nous sommes sur la commune
des remords est qui
est assez représentatif puisque
effectivement nous sommes dans un
endroit du parc qui est quand même assez
magnifique en lisière de forêt de
rambouillet on a essayé effectivement de
rester sur le patrimoine local et
proposer des choses
voilà tout en restant en adéquation avec
l'environnement surtout les objectif
premier c'est de se faire connaître et
surtout proposer aux parisiens qui sont
très amateur de break au vert de devenir
souffler un petit peu par chez nous
dosez passe est périphérique et de venir
nous voir en vallée de chevreuse des
objectifs qui s'accomplissent déjà très
bien pour une association qui ne compte
pas se reposer sur ses acquis en
cherchons toujours plus d'hébergeur dans
le parc propriétaire d'un gîte en vallée
de chevreuse vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à faire